Yeah.
Well those are two very
different called questions.
How can you help your parents
to sort themselves out?
Well,
I guess the first question would be,
uh,
or do they want to sort themselves out
because it's not that easy to help people
if they don't want to be helped.
Um,
if they do want to be helped.
Like listening is really a good strategy.
Um,
you know,
people,
you got the question right?
Because you said,
how can I help my parents
to sort themselves out,
which is very different than
how can I sort my parents out?
Um,
you help people
to sort themselves out once they have
decided to do so by giving them the
opportunity to talk about their concerns
and also to outline what potential
solutions might be and you don't want to
offer any pieces of advice while you're
doing that because it turns out that
people are much more likely to implement a
strategy of improvement if
they generate it themselves.
And then also you don't steal
the accomplishment from them.
Like,
let's say you came to me with
a bunch of problems and I said,
well,
here's what you can do about that.
And then you went out
and did it and it worked.
And then then in some sense
that's not your accomplishment.
I mean it is in so far as you implemented,
but it's not in so far as it
was something that I planned.
And you're intimation of that your
intimation of the fact that the
delight in success in the responsibility
for six success might've been stolen
from you by well meaning advice is going
to interfere with the probability that
you'll implement the solution.
And so it's best to let people
talk through their own problems.
Like,
well,
what's the problem?
That's what you ask.
What's the problem?
What do you think's not
write about your life?
And then people will throw in a bunch
of things that they're complaining about
or resentful about and,
and it might be quite an extensive list
and they'll feel guilty about it because
they don't want to burden you with it,
but they need to get
it all off their chest.
Right?
They need to get the cards on the table.
It's also something to know when you're
talking to your wife for your husband or
your intimate partner or
a child for that matter,
so when you have a close
relationship with this,
if they've got some
things to complain about,
which they undoubtedly do,
they're going to complain about a lot
more things than they're actually upset
about because they'll have gathered up
irritations that have been unspoken and
aggravations and fears and they'll all
be upsetting them emotionally and they
don't know exactly what they
are until they articulate that,
you know,
we say,
well,
what are you upset about?
Well,
I don't know.
how can you not know?
Well,
the answer is there's all sorts of things
that you respond to emotionally before
you can articulate them.
Then you get upset and you explode and
you yell and you lay out all the things
you might be angry about and you're
impulsive and you your case and you accuse
people of things that you
don't even believe all of.
That's part of the process of
laying your cards out on the table.
You have complex situations
that are disturbing you and
you don't know what they
are.
Exactly.
You have to kind of guess.
So you say,
well,
it might be this and it might be that,
and it might be this,
it might be you,
and this is why it's your fault.
You get accused Tori,
and then if you're listening to all that,
you have to just be patient and let the
person get all their cards out on the
table.
Even if some of that involves
accusations about you,
which you don't have to do immediately,
you don't have to immediately jump to
the conclusion that those accusations are
accurate or that you
have to defend yourself.
You know,
and I'm not,
believe me,
I'm not saying this is
easy because it's not,
but you listen to the
person lay out there,
their deck of complaints,
and the first thing you'll find is
that they will take 50% or maybe more,
75% of the cards off the table right away.
Because once they've
articulated out those concerns,
they'll find that they're
not really central.
They're not really the issue.
And so that leaves a smaller
number of genuine problems.
And then you can ask people again,
well,
here's the problem.
Can you think of any way,
if you could conceptualize how things
would be better in relationship to that
problem?
Well what would a solution
look like even in principle?
And then they might say,
well,
I don't know.
And then they have to guess and lay
their cards out on the table about what a
solution might look like if
they say they don't know,
that often means they don't
want to think about it.
And a little bit of encouragement isn't
in order and maybe a little bit of
pressure.
Um,
but you want people to formulate a vision
of what the situation would look like
if the problem was solved.
And then they might find it very
daunting because the solution looks so
difficult that they don't
see any pathway to it.
And so then the next part
of the discussion is,
well,
are there some things that you could do
that would be small steps that you would
be interested in doing that you think
you would do that would move you to the
solution?
And maybe those things
could be implemented.
Tentatively behavioral psychologists
call that collaborative and parasitism.
So you'll come and see a behavioral
psychologist and lay out your problems and
then the two of you
will negotiate towards,
uh,
the beginnings of a solution.
What could you do this week that might
make that problem slightly better?
And so you talked through what's
practical and what's implementable.
And you have to be honest about that
because you don't want to set yourself up
with a plan that's so complicated,
you won't implement it.
Then you say to the person,
if you're the psychologist,
you say,
well look,
we've got a couple of ideas about what
you could do this week that might make
this situation slightly better.
Why don't you go and implement them and
then come back next week and we'll talk
about whether or not that worked and work
would be you did implement it and that
it did have the desired solution.
And if it didn't work,
meaning you didn't implement it
or the solution didn't emerge,
then there's,
there's the opportunity for renegotiation.
So you can think about it strategic.
The first issue is if something
needs to be sorted out.
The first question is,
well,
what the hell is the problem?
And the answer that is,
you probably don't know.
The problem is I'm upset and disturbed
and angry and resentful and bitter and
unhappy and anxious and
in pain and lonesome,
I'm suffering from an excess of negative
emotion and perhaps from a certain
amount of hopelessness.
So the problem is the
emotional circumstance and
that might be associated with
some real problems,
right?
Some real practical problems.
So you lay all that out and say,
okay,
well what is the problem
landscape look like?
Right?
So that's the strategic move.
And then as I said that we'll generally
simplify the problem landscape.
Then you do things,
the same thing with a set
of potential solutions.
Well what would the solutions look like?
Cause you're not going to be able to
solve a problem unless you at least know
what a solution might look like.
That would actually,
um,
what would you say that would,
that you would find acceptable?
And then the next pro issue is to lay
out the strategies for the attainment of
that solution.
And you know,
sometimes it might be some of
these solutions might be dismal.
Like,
you know,
if you've got someone
who's ill in your family,
the solution might be,
well well we need a cure.
You know,
that's the only solution
that will suffice.
But you don't know how to pursue
the cure or maybe one doesn't exist.
And so then you have to think of while
a lower order and less satisfying
solution,
which would be,
well maybe we can cope,
we're going to learn to cope with this
so that it's the least amount of hell
possible.
And,
and maybe that,
maybe that even that's too much.
You might have to say,
well,
we're going to try to make this next
week when we're coping with this better
than the last week.
You know,
and,
and maybe you can't even do that.
It has to just be the next day.
You look for whatever small steps forward
you can take that will make things
less wretched and horrible
than they currently are.
You know,
to put it rather bluntly.
And that requires the
willingness to face the problem,
the humility to know that you
don't have the solution at hand.
The willingness to listen to how the
other people that you're talking to
formulate the problems and
formulate the solutions.
It's crucially important,
right?
To have them do that work themselves.
It's,
it's also,
you could think about it this way too,
is that if you listen to
someone come up with a solution,
you don't undergo the neurological
transformation is necessary to change your
character.
But if you come up with
the solutions yourself,
you know,
if you articulate the problem
and you articulate the solutions,
then you've changed your own character
in a way that increases the probability
that you're going to act out.
What you do.
And that requires real patients to let
people stumble through to their own
problems,
solutions,
because someone might lay out a
set of problems and you think,
oh my God,
I know what you could do about that,
but it doesn't really matter if you know.
You know?
And I'm also not saying that
sometimes advice is helpful.
You know,
sometimes you can give someone a hint,
but man,
you have to be careful with that because
there's a real element of theft that's
associated.